[Music]
in homeless resume news homeless resume
that's what it says so it's like a back
of a cardboard box then you might all
you're like I think I think so yeah it's
impressive actually he's really smart
somebody might crank that mm-hmm
not a song I feel like it is and we're
just I've been to a club in like ten
years damn old yeah
a homeless man who went viral is making
people question why we care so much
about his story in particular literally
like majority of news that I'm reading
that's some real news right that's
amazing yeah I love this word why should
we care why the [ __ ] do we care why do
some normal [ __ ] happens like humans are
supposed to try and go to college
or try to do better but was just like oh
my god can you believe it there with the
college or it's like this guy got beat
up at a park now he they got to go Fahmy
raise half a million dollars for him
it's like damn dude when I was a kid
people's got beat up sometimes I mean it
makes people like their life goals
become like you dope at the park so they
fit that five hundred thousand or it's
like they found this homeless guy peeing
on the side of the street so they did it
go fund me for 150 K and they bought in
his own outdoor toilet and that sounds
pretty accurate to what you see in that
[ __ ] nowadays that instead of helping
him get back on his feet I mean like
it's always something like that my edit
you look it up you're like man told us
like three hundred bucks like a plumbing
dude yeah customs buffer Kickstarter
it's like poor college student but he
loves fish
he loves aquariums you know we just got
your [ __ ] up car and we got a we got a
coffee machine cuz you're a student and
then we [ __ ] put an aquarium in pimp
my car yeah pick my homeless
all right so this tweets went viral
it says today I saw this young homeless
man asking for people to take a resume
rather than asking for money if anyone
in the Silicon Valley could help him out
that would be amazing please retweet so
we can help David out this photo it says
homeless hungry for success take a
resume and then the other you know
what's so smart about this guy he's
probably not homeless but then the jobs
come to him instead of he's like I don't
want to go to door-to-door I want people
to come to me that's hella good in any
viral and now he's like how much he's
like sorry cop pick up the phone of us
is 15 Mara thanks you don't say and then
and then his friends like wait no it
wasn't that a little aggressive and he's
like watch it'll ring again I mean when
you go viral you see you that cocky
[ __ ] vibe that's pretty clean his
experience is freelance web developer he
also worked at General Motors he got an
education at Texas A&M University he got
a BBA in management information system
whatever the [ __ ] that absolutely
college degrees don't guarantee of life
with security I am [ __ ] shocked where
are you going with this job I mean we
spend so much time and money and effort
trying to get into college II find
anything in college get the mortgage
collars now yeah and he probably has
college debt and suppose like the meme
is not true that's sad man in Silicon
Valley huh although you from teh house
yeah he moved from Texas and he was just
saying life is dream to have a job there
to work for a for a big company
and so this this tweet went viral no he
has Google of Pandora Bitcoin calm and
others reaching out since the story blew
up they all needed janitors or something
yeah what are they good for what yeah
what position for information
development services what information
development service that's exactly what
I think it it I think it is I think it's
like when you're at the mall and you
like hey man where's this thing he's
like a three downstairs take a little
bit yeah yeah well I guess he's a web
developer so that's perfect does the
digital pen so we're talking about like
first level homeless someone who's
temporarily like not having a home he
doesn't have an addiction he's homeless
because he had a hard time cuz when I
hear homeless you know what kind of
homeless I'm thinking about dudes with
two teeth jacking off on a street corner
somehow they have a [ __ ] smartphone
still one toe sticking out of the shoe
yelling random things about money and
the devil and Illuminati we were writing
the other day the person checking
themselves in reflection oh yeah yeah
I'm saying that was a fashionable
homeless - it's like a hoochie homeless
yeah yeah
like it was a dude with a crop top and
he was kind of checking himself out on
jeans [ __ ] shame himself out yeah
yeah showed his midriffs [ __ ] you
know getting it all together
yeah me tying his belt yeah so David it
said that he cashed out his burrow on
cave drove to Silicon Valley and his I
miss said his dream his dream was to
start up a tech company but now he's
he's being inundated with job offers so
they're saying that he has 200 job
offers now and then he struck him out he
hired someone to help them sort it out
yeah all right holy [ __ ] that's pretty
genius so
homeless right now because I feel like
you know most people are probably
sending 200 resumes and applications in
and this guy's getting 200 offers yeah
so he is what a hot girl is for jobs
he's sitting there choosing I like you I
don't like you I kind of like you I
maybe wanna be with you forever but you
may be temporary
it's like categorized by pay except job
with taeyang's pay Owen highest-paid
least amount of work always lots of fun
and maybe purpose yeah but if this is
just starting a conversation as to why
we care so much about him but not all
the other homeless people for what
because he's helping himself to a better
life a different story that's why yeah
for sure but I guess they're just saying
like you know he did have a leg up he
had a 401k to cash out he got a
education which is a privileged homeless
man right that's what we're doing nice I
love this [ __ ] that's like if if a three
teeth homeless person was up against a
five teeth home you have bowlers still I
don't exactly I can't eat apples anymore
yes you can well this one's just a gum
homeless only comes it's like shut the
[ __ ] up dude everyone's in different
stages of homelessness [ __ ] I'm like one
step away from that [ __ ] yeah maybe
you're a homeless person and you you
never even owned a home you you were in
an apartment you were kicked off and
there's people that live in their cars
there's people that are just gone beyond
help like they can't even hold down a
job because they're too busy like doing
kung fu against demons and [ __ ] again
Stevens's it's funny we all that because
we've actually all seen that I've
definitely seen that more than once a
lot of crackheads somehow know martial
arts
does the other day we were exiting the
freeway and there's like this wire fence
and there's a bunch of like water
bottles and this homeless dude was just
welcomed doing karate on the water
bottles so you had some appears I'm done
here so you know like that that [ __ ]
Chinese think that the [ __ ] Wing Chun
like wouldn't manly thing yeah he was
just doing that he was fucked-up life
but he was out his whole heart wasn't a
kid and he would reset it like once he
knocked one out of the fence he had on
order to pick up that bottle and screw
it back in and he would be there and you
would like damn this was really getting
his fitness on against on the fight Nixa
which meant like that was his training
center like its training for those
demons it's good to do that we don't
live I find yeah cuz I'm right at home
it's not as it's not as you know kitten
yeah yeah it's always done in a very
busy intersection or something like that
you know cuz you want the energy of the
cars to really like bring you up and you
get it he channels is homeless dogs
wondering why and you answered all my
questions
dude yeah I feel like that's how martial
arts was invented by like a homeless guy
on opium in China or something you know
you're like ah dude I think like it's so
crazy cuz they all have this innate need
to like do kung fu and it's
multicultural doesn't matter if you're
black or white or whatever like they're
all doing kung-fu and it all looks very
similar and it comes from that drunken
master technique you know it's that
[ __ ] drunk and start fighting
everything and the movements are so so
awesome like damn you guys in the clip
of Bruce Lee fighting Chuck Norris
there's movies from the movie yeah
it's freaking dope they're fast it's so
fast it's really cool horses fur yes but
that forgot like shoulder pads of fur
and at one point Bruce Lee like grabs
his chest hair [ __ ] go again so cool
though and he had nothing else to cut to
cuz they're in this like obviously in
the sound stage were [ __ ] cat so they
keep hitting this [ __ ] cat just
meowing and walking around it's
hilarious dude that's cool wait I love
how that was cool back then like I'm
gonna rip this [ __ ] chest hair
out that met your manly hood though like
men they were like oh you got chance on
here and now you're [ __ ] man well it
was also mocking too because Bruce Lee
was like dolphin [ __ ] skin not a hair
on his whole body hi yeah right and
chuck was not so he was like mom Chuck
was Harry's ball he was he pooped his
back for the team but he missed a spot
I couldn't help her shoulder because it
was patchy like this sucks a lot of red
hair up here and I was like Danny missed
a spot there but wardrobe didn't help
him out with that but back that up maybe
the girls like that yeah there's some
girls that get off on it oh yeah oh yeah
hairiness and the girls were hearing -
[Music]
isn't that coming back now is it
god no kill me now kill me let me die I
can't believe this coming back never dip
that's a bad day that's a bad coming you
stop that's what I say no way
[Music]
[Music]